hello and welcome to the sheiki science
show where in this video i'm going to
summarize the progress update
that was provided by neuralink yesterday
specifically we're going to look at the
change in
architecture of their device and their
goals for this adjury process then we'll
talk about the three little pigs
and the cool advance being made in the
reversibility of these devices
and then i'll discuss in more detail
more the technology and science behind
this devices
as they discussed it in a bit more
detail in this progress update than they
did in their original announcement a
year ago
and then at the end i'll talk about what
their vision is
and my thoughts on the company and the
device
so firstly what is neurolink well
neuralink is an american neurotechnology
company
founded by elon musk back in july 2016
and they are trying to develop
implantable brain machine
interfaces the main purpose of this
device is to be able to solve
important brain and spine problems with
a seamlessly implanted device
i said this has the potential to treat
different neurological problems
such as memory loss hearing loss
insomnia extreme pain paralysis
brain damage addiction and strokes just
a couple of examples
and to summarize how this brain machine
interface could achieve this in a simple
statement
it is purely by exploiting the fact that
different neurons within the brain
communicate via electrical signals these
electrical signals are generated by the
movement of
positive ions across the membrane of
neurons when the signal reaches the end
of a neuron
there's a chemical signal that transmits
it to the next neuron
that then has another wave of electrical
signals that transmits through it
the way that neurolink can exploit this
information
using their brain machine interfaces is
by being able to detect these electrical
signals
that they refer to as spikes that are
otherwise referred to as
action potentials and so they can
effectively read the signal of the
neurons
but more than just being able to read
these signals they can also stimulate
the activity of these neurons
so what sets neurolink apart from other
currently available devices
that can manipulate and read neuronal
signals
is the architecture of their neuralink
device
and so this architecture has actually
changed from what i described in my last
video talking about
neuralink so this is best seen in this
image here where you can see last summer
they had a device
that was actually behind the ear
connecting to these individual devices
that were being able to
record the neuronal activity whereas now
they've simplified it
whereby now there's just a queen-sized
device
that replaces part of the skull and
connects to
the cortex the outer region of the brain
by
tiny wires that they refer to as threads
so the company refers to this device as
link
and each link contains 1024 channels
and the idea is that this device is so
small
that it is flush with the skull so it
actually replaces the
region of the skull that's cut out and
so the idea is that you won't be able to
see it
it will only leave a small scar such
that you wouldn't necessarily be able to
tell that someone's even got the implant
and
elon actually jokes within this um
update conference that
he could have one and we wouldn't
actually be able to tell so the main
point is that this device is therefore
portable and the other neat feature is
the fact that
obviously this is an electrical device
it needs to be charged
and so the device can be inductively
charged and so
it can be used up during the day and
then charged at night without
needing any wires to connect between the
device and some power supply
so all of this has been designed with
practicality
possibility and a new visual appeal
in mind however it leaves another
problem which is
how can the signals be interpreted and
then
stimulated in a manner that is most
effective
without being connected to some computer
so this is the idea behind
brain machine interfaces so firstly you
need to be able to detect the signal
and as i mentioned before this is by
measuring the electrical signal
recorded from these neurons but then
secondly
that signal needs to be interpreted and
understood
and once it's understood that new
sensory information can be fed back into
the brain to stimulate the neurons
and so this interpretation of the signal
can either happen in the
outside world or it could happen on chip
that means happening
on the device such that there isn't a
need for an external interaction between
the device
and some other device whether it's a
computer or a phone
and so the more neurons that can be
detected by the devices
the better the predictions can be and
therefore the better and more effective
the stimulation and feedback to the
brain can be so the two major challenges
that neuralink faces
is one being able to get these devices
these implantable technologies
into the brain in an accurate and
minimally invasive manner without
causing any risk and brain damage
and secondly being able to understand
and interpret this data using algorithms
that can detect
the frequency and shape of these
neuronal signals and actually try and
understand them and interpret what they
mean
to be able to correctly stimulate and
feedback to the brain
so the first challenge can be solved by
having virtuously automated
system and so in this more recent
updates they showed more info about
their robotic systems that can actually
do this implants so this is what one of
their surgical robots currently looks
like
and the idea is that getting a link
could be a process
pretty much done all done by this one
surgical robot
making the process less than an hour
whereby you could leave the hospital the
same day and it could be done without
general anesthesia and if you're a
little bit squeamish maybe just look
away for a moment but what you can see
in this image is the precision with
which the surgical robot can insert the
different threads
and this insertion is so precise that it
can deal with the fact that the brain
actually kind of it moves as you breathe
um
and so this insertion can happen without
any bleeding
causing minimum risk to the patient and
automating the whole process and making
it efficient
and the safest way it could be done and
reproducible
so currently this insertion is limited
to the cortical surface
the outer region of the brain but in
theory by having longer threads
they could go deeper into the brain in
the future
but there's a lot of low-level
processing that actually occurs in the
cortex
such as motor responses sensory and
visual interpretations
as well as auditory responses and so by
having
the stimulation within the cortex it
could be used to
solve paralysis and so the second
challenge of being able to interpret and
understand
these signals comes down to do these
link devices actually work and so this
question was raised in the
new update conference and we're
introduced to three little pigs
gertrude joyce and dorothy and so the
difference between these pigs
is the fact that joyce didn't receive
any implants while skertry did
and dorothy is i suppose the most
intriguing and interesting
update to come from this announcement
was actually given one of the implants
but later on it had the implant removed
and so this demonstrates the
reversibility
of these devices and so all of these
pigs are healthy and happy
but the only insight we get to whether
or not these devices work
is from the real live demo of gertrude
who as
i just mentioned has one of these
neurolink implants and
gertrude actually has the neurolink
implants
connected to neurons that are in her
snout and so
i'll put the link to the progress update
in the description but
if you've already seen it you'll know
that you hear these beeps which are real
time signals coming from the snout
such that you hear the beeps every time
the snout is touching something
effectively
and so this real-life demo demonstrates
that you can
read these spikes you can read the
electrical activity
in real time from these 1024 electrodes
and the second bit of information we get
about these devices working
is from other studies they've done why
they've had pigs on a treadmill
and they've been able to record the
brain activity and try and predict
the position of the limbs and so using
their predicted information they can
compare it to the actual position of the
limbs
and see how effective their algorithm in
terms of under
understanding and interpreting these
neuronal signals are
and so i think from from the information
given so far
seems like the device is able to read
the brain activity
what isn't so clear yet is how effective
if at all it is at being able to write
and feedback into the brain
and so hopefully in later updates we'll
get more insight into this
so so far we've seen it in pigs and just
to point out
one of the arguments for using pigs is
they're quite a good model
in terms of having similar anatomy to
humans
and similar biomechanics and the fact
that
they have relatively low needs and so
their welfare is pretty
well kept and neurolink have published
onto youtube
a separate video talking more about the
treatment of the animals that they have
for their testing but what about humans
well
it was also announced by elon that
they're now heading towards human
clinical studies
they've received fda breakthrough device
designation in july
and so they're now preparing for first
human implantation
soon pending uh required approvals and
further safety testing
and this human clinical trial is
currently
said to be for tetraplegia which is
paralysis caused by illness or injury
that results in partial or total loss of
use of all four limbs and torso
and so the idea is that by thinking
about movement
the neurolink device will be able to
induce the movement
and to overcome this paralysis so the
short-term goal of
neurolink is to be able to treat these
different neurological disorders
but what about the long-term potential
of neurolink
well one of elon's visions is to
eventually as a long-term goal be able
to preserve and enhance your own brain
including examples such as being able to
record
and store your memories being able to
better understand
consciousness and to have superhuman
vision and telepathy
and the idea is he would like to create
a well-aligned future whereby there's
full brain machine interface
and symbiosis with artificial
intelligence
so some of these more interesting
updates came from the question and
answer section at the end of their
presentation
and one of the big major questions was
on the security of the device
and the company announced that it should
be encrypted and
authenticated and it's obviously
something that they're taking into
account whilst developing these
different models
and the other concern is obviously
always going to be the safety
and the long-term preservation of these
different models
within the brain which is obviously a
very corrosive
environment and so this heavily depends
on material science
and the different materials actually
used to create these devices
such that they can easily still be able
to detect and measure the electrical
signals and feedback
whilst having insulation from the
external and surrounding environments
and so this is what i was saying about
earlier that it's a good achievement for
them to
show now that it these implants are
effectively reversible and can be taken
out
for example if there was any defects or
cause
for concern about it causing damage
within the brain
and also it provides a way of then
providing new
updated models that can then be replaced
so
it to some extent would circumvent the
need for it to
to last for extended periods of time and
instead maybe
between the time range of five to ten
years however what i think really is a
major concern for the company
in these devices is one how effective
their stimulation can be
as i said the reading might be quite
good but it's more important to be able
to get the correct and effective writing
and that stimulation back into the brain
for it to be
an effective device for example you
don't want unwanted movements
or unwanted consequences neither do you
want the system to be hacked by
interference with other people nearby
who've also got devices
they could be stimulating your leg
movement i mean i have no idea
whether that's even possible but there
are all kind of questions that need to
be raised at an early stage before
these kind of wild abstract ideas are
kind of put in people's heads
i think there's a lot of work to be done
in terms of the safety of these devices
and also
the longevity in terms of whilst using
these devices might be able to
treat age-associated diseases such as
loss of vision
memory loss and improved um
control over your movements there's also
the concern of
would it reduce your lifespan or health
span
by having these devices because it's
over stimulating the brain potentially
or um requiring more any brain power
and i think there could be there could
be unintended consequences that maybe
haven't been considered yet
and so i'm a little bit skeptical i
think the idea of this link device is
great in terms of treating neurological
disorders
going further than that at the moment
i'm a little bit on the fence i think
i'd have to wait to see
more of their research but what i can
say is all these new announcements
are very exciting and interesting and
yeah
um the other thing i haven't mentioned
is the cost according to the q
a um obviously initially they probably
will be quite expensive but
elon infidence said eventually it could
come down to a few thousand dollars
however that would still mean that isn't
an accessible price to everyone
and so all i can really summarize from
that is what elon also says
which is the future's going to be weird
and i
think i do agree with him on that it
kind of summarizes it all very well
it's very exciting research it's
something we've never really seen before
and i mean i'm excited interested a
little bit scared a little bit skeptical
but i think we can only wait and see to
find out more so
hopefully you've learned something from
this very
condensed summary um and as always
thanks for listening